l'une des plus graves inondations du
siècle ravage le soudan la crue du nil a
déjà tué 60 personnes et fait plus de
deux millions de sinistrés
radiesthésiste mobilisation des amis
appel à l'armée la famille de pauline
lafont met tout en oeuvre pour retrouver
l'actrice disparue il ya plus de 72
heures pour trois jours douarnenez se
veut capitale de la voile celle du temps
jadis 500 voiliers vont vous faire la
fête de la mer madame monsieur bonsoir à
la une ce soir la crue du nil au soudan
en 24 heures les eaux du fleuve ont
monté de 14 cm c'est l'une des plus
graves inondations de l'histoire du
soudan et de l'histoire du siècle
deux millions de personnes sont
sinistrées à khartoum la capitale
plusieurs dizaines de personnes ont été
entraînées par les eaux une catastrophe
qui frappe l'un des pays les plus
pauvres du monde
pascal deschamps c'était le verger du
soudan ce n'est plus aujourd'hui qu'un
immense marécage debout en dix jours les
paysans de cette région ont tout perdu
leurs maisons et leurs récoltes
périchole qui ne suffisait déjà pas à
nourrir la population d'un pays en
majorité désertique
c'est ici au nord de khartoum la
capitale que des pluies torrentielles
ont dangereusement gonfler les eaux du
nil bleu depuis le 4 août
sa largeur à quadruples et résultat des
dizaines de morts des centaines de
milliers de sans abri des voies de
communication déjà rares détruite une
ville entière ait barre à couper du
monde et un fleuve qui a atteint sa cote
d' alerte et qui menace maintenant
d'inonder le centre de khartoum
autres zones touchées les faubourgs
misérables de la capitale là où
s'entassent les réfugiés venus du sud
chassés par la famine et la guerre
civile il faut maintenant nourrir et
relogées près de deux millions de
sinistrés
une fois encore l'aide internationale a
repris le chemin du soudan des vivres
des tentes des couvertures mais une fois
encore des réfugiés se plaignent de la
lenteur de l'approvisionnement au maire
noël type le responsable des secours
explique c'est vrai que certaines
personnes n'ont pas reçus grand chose
mais les zones sinistrées sont
difficiles à atteindre
l'électricité a été coupée mais peu à
peu nous arrivons à tour établir hier
les soudanais avaient commencé à
reprendre espoir
les trombes d'eau de la nuit dernière
ont réduit leurs efforts à 0 et déjà la
pluie menace à nouveau en afghanistan la
résine ans la résistance a de nouveau
bombardé la capitale la nuit dernière
les roquettes ont tué cinq civils des
femmes et des enfants
une dizaine d'autres ont été blessées
voyez ici les images que viennent de
nous faire parvenir la télévision de
kaboul malgré l'armée afghane il semble
de plus en plus évident que les rebelles
occupent le terrain laissé libre par le
retrait du corps expéditionnaire
soviétique 50 mille hommes de l'armée
rouge auront quitté demain l'afghanistan
conformément aux accords de genève un
retrait confirmé par les observateurs de
l'onu gilles rabin
ces commandos de l'armée rouge pour une
démonstration de leurs techniques de
combat rapproché à usage de leur allié
communiste afghan former le plus vite
possible un maximum de soldats capables
de prendre leur relève sur le terrain
c'est aujourd'hui l'obsession des
soviétiques en afghanistan depuis le 15
mai chaque fois qu une garnison où un
groupe de combat soviétique se retire
les résistants attaque les positions
abandonnées
toutes les grandes capitales
provinciales de la montagne subissent
les assauts permanent de la résistance
qui harcèlent jusqu'à la frontière les
convois de l'armée rouge
malgré tout les soviétiques ont tenu
leurs engagements ils ont retiré près de
57 mille hommes
la moitié de leur corps expéditionnaire
avant la date du 15 août une date butoir
prévue par les accords de genève sur
l'afghanistan
les observateurs de l'onu pense
cependant que le rythme des retrait
soviétique va se ralentir maintenant
moscou cherchant à maintenir le maximum
de troupes possible jusqu'à l'arrivée de
l'hiver l'hiver afghan qui donnera un
délai supplémentaire au régime de kaboul
pour tenter de contenir la poussée de la
résistance pas de liberté sans
solidarité c'était l'un des slogans
entendus tout à l'heure en pologne une
manifestation à gdansk sur la côte
baltique contre le pouvoir a dégénéré
plusieurs centaines de polonais ont
affronté les forces de l'ordre selon des
témoins les miliciens auraient passé à
tabac plusieurs manifestants lech walesa
participaient à cette démonstration
organisée devant l'église sainte
brigitte à gdansk en corée du sud on
pourrait certes ne penser qu'aux jeux
olympiques dont la cérémonie inaugurale
aura lieu dans cinq semaines
mais l'entêtement des étudiants à
réclamer plus de démocratie et la
réunification du pays a provoqué ce
matin une nouvelle guerre de rue à séoul
louis carzou pour le troisième jour
consécutif les étudiants se sont
affrontés aux policiers anti émeutes
sont les principaux campus de séoul
cocktails incendiaires contre grenade
lacrymogène les revendications des
étudiants qualifiés de radicaux par le
gouvernement sont toujours les mêmes
réunification des deux corées et départ
des troupes américaines basées dans le
pays depuis 1953
les événements de ces derniers jours
préparer la marche
doit avoir lieu lundi apam john où les
étudiants des deux corées doivent se
rencontrer
une rencontre interdite par le
gouvernement sud coréen le même
gouvernement vient de libérer 1400
prisonniers politiques et compte de plus
en plus sur l' isolement des étudiants
au sein de la population en majorité peu
mobilisés sur le thème de la
réunification des sud coréens semblent
surtout soucieux à présent du bon
déroulement des jeux olympiques qui
doivent s'ouvrir le 17 septembre
la birmanie est entré dans une phase de
trêve armes et les rues de rangoon ont
retrouvé aujourd'hui leurs marchands et
leurs piétons là même où la semaine
dernière la troupe tiré pour disperser
les manifestants les opposants au régime
notamment les étudiants attendent du
successeur de sin win le dictateur déchu
qu'il mette fin au système du parti
unique et qui libère les détenus
politiques
l'accalmie se traduit également sur les
marchés ou les produits de première
nécessité comme le riz ont réapparu en
quantité ce dimanche la situation est
très difficile dans les territoires
occupés par israël à l'occasion de la
nouvelle année musulmane dans la bande
de gaza la grève générale est très suivi
et la répression menée par l'armée
israélienne a fait ce seul week end
trois morts dont un garçon de 12 ans
nicolas jacobs patrouilles incessantes
des forces armées israéliennes grèves
générales très suivies à l'appel de la
résistance islamique
les territoires occupés de gaza et de
cisjordanie ont vécu aujourd'hui sous
haute tension le nouvel an musulman
depuis hier ces territoires sont à
nouveau secoué par des manifestations
violentes comme ici à rafah jets de
pierres cocktails molotov riposte des
soldats israéliens deux morts par balles
dont un enfant du côté des manifestants
ailleurs un jeune garçon aurait été
battu à mort accuse aussi les
palestiniens la raison de cette flambée
de violence qui s'est prolongée ce matin
la mort de deux palestiniens dans un
incendie criminel à tel aviv et
l'instauration d'un couvre-feu n'a pas
empêché la reprise de cette guerre des
pierres qui dure maintenant depuis près
de huit mois
à quelques semaines du conseil national
palestinien le numéro 2 de l'ol paie
abou iyad se prononce pour la formation
d'un gouvernement dans les territoires
occupés ce serait une réponse à la
rupture des liens entre la cisjordanie
la jordanie décidé par le roi hussein
pour le numéro deux de la centrale
palestinienne
le programme de ce gouvernement pourrait
intégrer à terme la reconnaissance
mutuelle d'israël et d'un état
palestinien
notre confrère britannique the observer
affirme que les otages anglais au liban
seront libérés dans les prochaines
semaines l'hebdomadaire cite une source
iranienne
ce serait le résultat le plus
spectaculaire d'une mission de
normalisation entre londres et téhéran
menés actuellement par le foreign office
voilà pour l'actualité très riche
aujourd'hui à l'étranger en france la
disparition de l'actrice pauline lafont
il y à plus de 72 heures maintenant sur
place dans les cévennes la famille
mobilise tous les moyens pour l'instant
il n'y a pas d'explication et les
témoignages sont contradictoires
patrice volée et bernie mériaux mais où
est donc passée pauline à
saint-andré-de-valborgne la question est
sur toutes les lèvres 48 heures de
recherches infructueuses pour gendarmes
et pompiers
aujourd'hui encore les parents les amis
de la famille les chasseurs du village
ont battu la montagne un travail
interminables dans le maquis des
cévennes quatre jours d'absence
inexpliquée au coeur de l'été la famille
garde le silence
jeudi dernier début de la matinée
pauline part seul en balade une marche à
pied de quelques kilomètres comme à son
habitude la région elle la connaît bien
c'est celle de son enfance aucun risque
a priori pourtant il ne reviendra pas
tout le secteur a été fouillé daisy hier
soir les gendarmes ont arrêté les
recherches au domicile de la famille la
faune ce soir l' angoisse de la tente se
mêle à l'espoir de recueillir un
témoignage de leur côté les gendarmes
s'orientent vers une enquête classique
fugue ou enlèvement sur le bord de la
route suite à une mauvaise rencontre
aucune hypothèse n'était écartée même si
pour la famille
la disparition de pauline sur un coup de
tête reste tout à fait improbable
bernadette lafont la mère de l'actrice
disais tout à l'heure son angoisse
totale ajoutant qu'elle n'avait
absolument aucune idée de ce qui a pu se
produire dans le var un commando de cet
homme a réussi à piller plusieurs
distributeurs de billets dans des
agences bancaires la nuit dernière
le butin est estimé à près de trois
millions de francs les malfrats avaient
pris en otage un technicien du crédit
agricole et sa femme enceinte de même
que plusieurs employés la surveillance
organisées sur les routes pour les
retrouver pour
trouver les auteurs de ce hold up n'a
pour l'instant rien donné demain
l'assomption la fête de marié à
l'origine de ce jour chômé donc de ce
long week-end il y a certes napoléon qui
marquait ainsi l'anniversaire de sa
naissance
mais tout a commencé avec le roi louis
xiii à une époque de grande piété où
l'on suivait les oracles pour mener les
guerres où l'on disait des neuvaines
pour provoquer la fécondité où l'on
construisait des maîtres tels à notre
dame
valérie fournier un roi offre sa
couronne
gage ultime de la royauté à l'église
nous sommes le 15 août 1638 louis xiii
roi de france et de navarre fait se veut
prenant la très sain et très glorieuse
vierge pour protectrice spécial notre
royaume
nous lui consacrons notre personne notre
état notre couronne et nos sujets louis
xiii demande d'oracle
la france est en pleine guerre d'espagne
et puis surtout il n'y a pas d'héritier
à la couronne le roi sera entendu louis
xiv n'est quelques mois plus tard et les
troupes françaises refoulent les
espagnols depuis de royauté en
république le vue de louis xiii a subi
quelques vicissitudes sous la révolution
qu'on a supprimé le 15 août
évidemment fête religieuse mais le
consulat a rétabli le 15 août comme fait
légale et napoléon a institué le 15 août
comme la scène napoléon qui fait que
c'était une fête nationale encore et
depuis jusqu'à louis philippe le 15 août
a été faite national avec procession
fêtes religieuses auxquelles les
puissances divines et religieux de veste
demain 15 août le cardinal lustiger va
renouer avec un rythme vieux de 350 ans
le célèbre jeu de lou 13 hérité d'un
temps où la france était une monarchie
et l'église liée à son histoire imaginée
35 mille sociétés ayant accès au paradis
fiscal l'ex dictateur marcos le
philippin il conserverait un peu
d'argent nous sommes au liechtenstein et
franz joseph de fête aujourd'hui ses 50
ans de règne c'est un record de
longévité que n'atteint même pas
l'empereur hirohito le japonais le
liechtenstein à 25000 sujet les femmes y
vote seulement depuis 1984 l'amnésie et
le franc suisse et l'impératrice sissi
et l attente du prince actuel pour le
reste le reportage de delphine de la
selle et de franck brisset seigneur de
challandes baer compte de van houtte
grand amateur de rubens van dyck
franz-josef deuxième du nom est
l'héritier du dernier vestige du
saint-empire romain germanique
liechtenstein un nom qui résonne comme
un coup de cravache pour cet état l'un
des plus petits et surtout l'un des plus
riches du monde
coincé entre le rhin et l'autriche à 80
kilomètres de zurich
la principauté alpine n'a rien n'à
royaume d'opérette et pour les banquiers
homme fort du pays
le liechtenstein est pas uniquement
paradis fiscal juste est noir et très
travailleur et il économise ils payent
moins d'impôts qu'en suisse
est ce que chacun a sa maison il n'y a
pas de chômeurs au liechtenstein dit
même on a tellement de travail que les
suisses et les autrichiens bien
travaillé fini les impôts liechtenstein
sont d'ailleurs très bas
à la veille de la seconde guerre
mondiale c'était le pays le plus pauvre
d'europe
en 50 ans franz joseph ii et sa fortune
en ont fait le champion du monde du
niveau de vie de la prothèse dentaire et
de l'impression de timbres postaux
tout est trop simple trop beau et la
politique n'échappe pas à cette règle
il ya des parties les rouges et les
noirs mais il n'y a pas des vraies
différences entre les partis liés sont
les deux sont conservateurs et
monarchistes et on voit que les hommes
ou les autres parce que le père a voté
le même faire fuir cette eau le
liechtenstein n'est pas qu'une simple
boîte aux lettres pour quelques milliers
de sociétés internationales
attiré par une fiscalité bienveillante
son prince quand joseph ii est aussi
l'un des hommes les plus riches d'europe
trésor du royaume
sa collection réunit des centaines de
tableaux des plus grands maîtres de la
peinture classique
raphaël fragonard ici les rues basses
prêté une des plus grandes et des plus
anciennes collections privées du monde
son histoire est liée à la dynastie des
prince du liechtenstein
une histoire de quatre siècles tous les
dirigeants du pays les princes régnants
posséder et enrichit cette collection
aujourd'hui elle est inestimable
dernier détail il n'y a pas de frontière
entre la suisse et ce pays sans pauvreté
ni chômage
alors si l'auto route de vos vacances
passent à proximité lever le pied ou
risqueriez de traverser sans vous en
apercevoir
cet état souverain qui fait très
exactement 25 km de long sur 10 de large
et on dit lichtensteinois une histoire
en tout cas est un pays a classé sous le
terme générique prospérité il est des
situations moins enviable où la crise
économique fait de plus en plus de
laisser pour compte
à quelques centaines de kilomètres du
liechtenstein il ya à la gare centrale
de rome
marcel trillât ont vraiment abandonné
tout espoir ils sont venu échouer rhys
hill gare termini à deux pas de tous ces
trains qui partiront santé un café chaud
à sandwich un peu d'amitié les jeunes
volontaires de caritas secours
catholique italien ne peuvent pas faire
grand chose de plus mais il espère
toujours trouver quelqu'un par hasard
que l'on est encore une chance de tirer
vers le haut de la pente alors il
l'entend ici à loos tel lot le logis des
sans-logis aménagé il ya deux ans grâce
à la ténacité de monseigneur dj hero et
aux subventions de la mairie de rome sa
vie est un vieil habitué il ne dédaigne
pas de temps en temps le linge et evra
prof de l'hostel l'eau pour une nuit
dans un vrai lit sa façon à lui de se
payer une petite fête l'hostel l'eau
peut accueillir chaque nuit une
cinquantaine d'hommes et une trentaine
de femmes à l'autre bout de la ville la
mène sa le restaurant de caritas fournit
chaque jour 1500 repas gratuit une
goutte d'eau dans la misère de rome plus
de soixante-dix mille étrangers en
situation irrégulière africains surtout
sont à la dérive dans la capitale
italienne sans aucune ressource officiel
il y à aussi 60000 vieillards sans
autres revenus que les 1800 francs par
mois de la retraite des vieux les
chômeurs eux n'ont droit qu'à 10 francs
par jour environ
les malades ne sont guère mieux traités
comme cet ancien concierge de 54 ans
rendue invalide par une hémiplégie et
abandonné par sa famille 50 francs par
jour pour tenter de survivre
mais j'ai rien regarde
juste un billet de la loterie si je
gagne je deviens riche alors je me paye
la ville à la voiture je me paye même
une femme malheureusement tout dans mes
vous dans ma voiture
ma vieille voiture il y à bien la
possibilité de demander en cas d'urgence
une aide exceptionnelle mais c'est au
prix d'un combat harassant de plusieurs
mois contre la bureaucratie n'a plus
inerte d'europe 1 ce n'est pas vrai que
l'état soit au service de tous l'état
s'intéresse de plus en plus au secteur
qui rapport et qui représente des
intérêts économiques et il s'intéresse
de moins en moins aux difficultés et aux
droits des gens les plus pauvres cela
malheureusement ne peuvent compter que
sur les initiatives charitable deux ou
trois fois par semaine les volontaires
de la charité repartent combattre la
misère qui se cachent dans les replis de
la nuit de rome presque sans armes
nous allons parler maintenant d'un
exploit à venir dans près de trois mois
ce sont les 100 jours hors du temps que
la spéléologues véronique le guen a
décidé de passer dans un gouffre de
l'aveyron c'est près de millau
l'expérience est actuellement vieille de
quatre jours est le cobaye a déjà perdu
ses repères temporels claude crespo
quelques heures après avoir
symboliquement renoncer à 100 brasse les
montres véronique le guen est déjà hors
du temps
hier elle s'est réveillée à 13h30 après
une nuit longue de 13 heures passées
avec sa peluche et s'est couché à 6h45
toujours avec la peluche bref sans leur
père du soleil et sans une montre la
dernière journée de véronique a duré 28
heures michel siffre est un peu étonné
de ce rapide changement de rythme
biologique mais guère inquiet le
présenterai les mêmes couple vole 30
mairie par exemple
paris san francisco mais tant qu'elle
reste comme ça dans cette situation en
surface dans ce laboratoire toutes les
activités de véronique sont enregistrés
les renseignements ainsi compilé
permettront de servir de base d'études
de nombreuses expériences en particulier
les cycles de la femme hors du temps
dans le cadre de la détection du cancer
du sein et l'étude des rythmes de
sommeil ainsi que lors des
synchronisations un bien charmant
cobayes n'est-il pas et d'aucuns
voudraient bien sans hésiter prendre la
place soit de la peluche soit des
électrodes par exemple véronique le guen
à 31 ans elle est aussi plongeuse
confirmé il lui reste donc plus de deux
mois et demi à passer sous terre dans
son gouffre près de millau dans
l'aveyron au temps jadis on parlait du
misainier du slope ou du magot et
lettres du trois mâts goélette
aujourd'hui on en parle encore mais le
vapeur la vapeur et le moteur on
je mens supplanter la voile jusqu'à
demain douarnenez se veut capitale
européenne de la voile traditionnelle
histoire de réconcilier les français
avec leur patrimoine maritime
il y a dans la baie là-bas à près de 600
voiliers venus du monde entier
jean-marc brami vincent maillard le
trois mâts le plus célèbre de france le
belem croiser majestueux dans la baie de
douarnenez il est comme 600 autres
voiliers venus prouver qu'il n'existe de
vrais marinca voile enfin au moins
jusqu'à lundi dans le port breton les
élégances loupe en anglais côtoient de
modeste coque de noix créant un étrange
ballet pour la fête des bateaux
traditionnels organisé par la revue le
chasse-marée le sedov star des mers
manquent encore à l'appel du large mais
pas la cancalaise ce matin son équipage
a pris le départ de la course
accompagné de l'habituel crachin breton
28 tonnes de bore manoeuvre avec ardeur
un bateau long de 18 mètres
né dans la baie de saint michel il ya
plus d'un siècle la cancalaise c'est
l'exacte réplique de ses légendaires
bisquine qui se consacrait autrefois à
la pêche au chalut et au dragage 18
entre granville et cancale maîtrisons
pilotin du voilier et marin pêcheur lui
même en parle avec chaleur
c'est un spécimen unique la seule
bisquine qui navigue pour le moment et
qui était conservé une chance énorme
c'est que jean le bot
c'était un universitaire de rennes a
relevé la les plans de la perle apple
avant qu'elle soit détruite à la houle
quoi à cancale et il en a fait un livre
qui nous a permis de reconstruire le
bateau sans avoir à chercher on avait
absolument toutes les données
nécessaires
la cancalaise n'a pas gagné la régate ça
ne fait rien en arizona
les hommes ils seront de nouveau les
voiles lundi effectivement douarnenez
jusqu'à demain fête de la mer en sport
c'est la fin de la revue d'effectif à
tour aux championnats de france
d'athlétisme
aujourd'hui deux records parce qu'elle
lefebvre améliore celui qu'il possédait
déjà au javelot avec que 81 m 48 marie
josé pérec quant à elle améliore sur 400
mètres en 50 et une secondes et 31
centièmes le record détenu depuis 19 ans
par nicole duclos c'était à athènes
thierry boltz couloir 4 maillots blancs
cerclés de bleu la nouvelle reine de
l'athlétisme français
marie josé pérec en réalisant 50 et une
seconde 35 centièmes sur 400 m elle fait
tomber un record détenu depuis 19 ans
par nicole duclos marie jo avait un en
quatre mois et dix jours au moment du
record de duclos un fantastique exploit
pour cet athlète gracieuse qui réalise
une course exemplaire elle termine en
totale décontraction
400 m bon ça quand elle démontre qu'il
nous faut ce genre de france et ses
pronostics
tout d'abord par hyacinthe
c'est ballot 420 ch cette année j'ai
fait 1 4 temps aux interclubs
ah bon c'est la première ayant cette
année
et ensuite le budget en question c'était
à lille comme très bien marché je me
suis dit pourquoi pas leur corps de
nicole duclos
petite déception en revanche du côté de
gilles quénéhervé ici en short rouge au
couloir numéro 4 dont on attendait
beaucoup après sa brillante performance
de cette filière
mais sans doute un peu démotivé le
français réalise attend peu conforme à
ces dispositions actuelles il termine
troisième
laissant le titre de champion de france
à daniel sangouma en moto il ya eu
aujourd'hui une nouvelle épreuve du
championnat du monde en suède c'est
l'américain là où sonne qui s'est imposé
en cinq centimètres cubes
le français sarron et 3e de cette
catégorie en deux cent cinquante
centimètres cubes son frère dominique
sarron fini également troisième derrière
deux espagnols celui qui gagne est
l'espagnol le site au pont ce tiercé
quarté + société cet après midi à
deauville le tiercé la combinaison
gagnante et le 6 2 11
elle rapporte pour 5 francs dans l'ordre
8982 francs 50 dans un ordre différent
1796 francs et 50 centimes le quarté +
courcy francs combinaison gagnante 6 2
rouges 9 dans l'ordre 63 1544 francs et
80 centimes dans un ordre différent 3175
francs et 20 centimes
le trio rapporte 5 111 francs et 20
centimes
c'est la fin de ce journal
vous avez rendez vous dans un instant
avec laurent cabrol pour une météo de 15
ou qui doit être bonne malgré quelques
orages
vous aurez également un prochain rendez
vous d'information à 22h50 le journal
par bernard pradines au excellente
soirée à tous sur antenne 2
oui